[Müzik]
uzun ve yorucu bir günün ardından
Nihayet evdeyim ya da eğer evden
çalışıyorsam son görüşmemi yapmış son
mail'imi atmışım masamdan kalkıyorum
Karnımın acıkmış olduğunu fark edip
mutfağa doğru gidiyorum Bugün güzel bir
gün Bugün güzel bir gün Çünkü tadını çok
sevdiğim Akşam yemeğini bir gün önceden
hazırlamışım geriye sadece birkaç
dakikada ısıtmak ve tabaklamak kalmış
benim beslenme açısından Bugün güzel bir
gün dediğim favori durumlarımdan biridir
bu
bir diğeri de sabah lütfen güzel çıksın
diyerek kestiğim o tek avokadonun harika
çıktığını minik bir zafer saydığım o an
peki
Bundan sonra ne bekliyorum
yemek davranış çalışan bir diyetisyen ve
psikolog olarak yeme farkındalığı
açısından her zaman önermediğim bir
durum ama o gün bir çılgınlık yapıp
tabağıma alıp salona doğru gidiyorum
yumuşak koltuğuma Televizyonun
karşısında kuruluyorum geriye voltran'ı
oluşturmak için tek bir adım kaldı
yemeğin üzerinden yemeden ve soğutmadan
ne izleyeceğime karar vermek Hani
sinemaya gittiğinizde daha reklamlarda
biten Patlamış mısır sendromunu
yaşamamak acaba en sevdiğim dizinin en
yeni bölümünü izlesem danışanının
bahsettiği şu belgesellemin bir göz
atsam acaba babamı Görüntülü mü arasam
Yoksa hem ablama hem babamın Görüntülü
mü arasam Acaba ablam toplantıda mıdır
diye diye düşünürken Yemek bitti
güzel bir akşam geçirmek için çıktığım
bu yolda çoğu zaman kendimi bu şekilde
bulabiliyorum yani ne ihtiyacım
karşılanmış oluyor ya da yaptığım
tercihten tatmin olmuş oluyorum
buraya kadar anlattığım günün 10-15
dakikalık bölümünde bile ne kadar çok
tercih yapmamız gerekiyor ve önümüzde ne
kadar çok seçenek var
seçeneklerimizin çok olması ilk başta
kulağa çok hoş gibi görünüyor ancak
bilim bu konuda bizimle hemfikir değil
gibi görünüyor
2000 yılında yapılan çok bilindik bir
araştırmaya göre tüketicilerin
tercihlerinin artıyor olması aldıkları
tatminle ters orantılı olarak bulunuyor
araştırma şöyle başlıyor
araştırmanın 1 gününde bir süpermarkete
bir stand kuruluyor bu standın Üzerine
de 20 farklı çeşit reçel konuluyor Eğer
ki gelen müşteriler bu reçelleri
tadarlarsa bir dolarlık bir indirim
kuponu alacağı söyleniyor
araştırmanın ikinci günü de aynı şekilde
devam ediyor Ancak bu sefer standa 20
yerine 6 çeşit reçel konuluyor
araştırmanın iki günlük sonucuna
bakıldığında 20 farklı reçelin olduğu
gün çok daha fazla talep olmasına rağmen
6 çeşit reçelinin olduğu gün satış
rakamları çok daha yüksek bulunuyor
bunu takip eden araştırmalarda kişilerin
seçeneklerinin artıyor olması sadece
satış rakamlarını değil aynı zamanda
yaptıkları alışverişten olan
memnuniyetlerinin de benzer bir şekilde
daha düşük olduğunu gösteriyor yani
atıştırmalıklar Dondurmalar Gazlı
içeceklerin daha çok çeşitli bulunduğu
süpermarketlerde müşteri memnuniyetleri
Aslında daha düşük olarak bulunuyor
Peki 20 çeşit reçele de 20 farklı uzmana
da 20 farklı diyete de ulaşmanın bu
kadar kolay olduğu bu kadar
parmaklarımızın ucunda olduğu bir
dönemde aynı zamanda seçenekler artarken
kafa karışıklığımızın da benzer bir
şekilde artıyor olması neredeyse
Paradoks gibi değil mi
Evet tabii ki bu böyle Aynen benim akşam
önümde binlerce seçenek olmasına rağmen
bir türlü Ne istediğime karar veremeyip
tatmin olamayıp günümü bitirmem gibi
aynı şekilde
aynı kafa karışıklığı beslenme konusunda
da aslında yaşanıyor Acaba hangi diyet
daha iyi Karbonhidratlar mıydı yoksa
işte yağlar mı düşmanımızda ikisi mi
düşmanımızda bu uzmanlığı yoksa diğerine
mi gitsem diye diye düşünürken bir türlü
ne yapacağımıza karar veremiyorken
kendinizi bulabiliriz
Maalesef bugün de size en iyi diyetin ne
olduğunu sırrını veremeyeceğim Çünkü
maalesef böyle bir şey yok ancak kendi
ihtiyaçlarınızı anlayarak aklınızda
tutabileceğiniz beslenme ile ilgili
birkaç noktadan bahsetmek istiyorum
birincisi bilmek eşittir uygulamak ve
uygulatabilmek değildir
buna çok fazla
bir hakkındaki hedefinize ulaşacağınız
anlamına gelmez
hayatında yüzlerce kez Uçağa bindim
havacılıkla ilgili tahmin
edebileceğinizden çok daha fazla kitap
okuduğum belgesel izledim film izledim
zamanımı emeyim mi Hatta paramı bu
konuyu ayırdım Ama şu anda bir uçak ya
da Jet uçuramam
Çok acil bir durumda çok iyi bir kopilot
olabilirim belki bana söylenilenleri
harfi yani yerine getirebilirim ama
değişen koşullarda nasıl davranmam
gerektiği eğer bana öğretilmediyse
güvenli bir uçuş nasıl sağlayabilirim ki
benzer bir şekilde 50 kilo vermiş olan
bir kişinin de kendi uçağını nasıl
uçuracağı ile ilgili Eminim çok fazla
bilgi ve deneyimim olmuştur Ama kendi
uçağını uçurdu diye bir pilotluk kursu
açması bana yine pek güvenli gelmiyor
bilmekle ilgili bir diğer daha bahsetmek
istediğim konu o bildiğimiz her şeyi her
zaman uygulamak zorunda değiliz demin
bahsettiğim yemek farkındalığı örneğinde
olduğu gibi yeme farkındalığını çok iyi
bilmenize rağmen bazı zamanlarda
farkındalıkla yemeyebilirsiniz
bunların hiçbiri birer Kural değil
ihtiyaç duyduğunuzda kullanabileceğiniz
yöntemlerden sadece bir tanesi mesela
çok hızlı yemek yiyorsanız ya da
doyduğunuzu anlayamıyorsanız eğer o
zaman televizyonsuz bir ortamda belki
birkaç kez alıştırma yapabilirsiniz
benzer bir şekilde bilmek için
Okuduğunuz makaleleri de ya da
Seçtiğiniz kitapları da ihtiyaçlarınıza
göre seçmeniz çok önemli mesela
glutensiz beslenme ile ilgili bir kitap
okumuş olabilirsiniz bir sohbet dinlemiş
olabilirsiniz ama Çölyak hastası
değilseniz glutensiz beslenmeye Aslında
ihtiyacınız yok
ikinci bahsetmek istediğim konu avokado
yemeden de sağlıklı olabilir ve kilonuzu
yönetebilirsiniz
avokado yemediği için ya da brokoli
yemediği için çocuğunun yeteri miktarda
büyüyemeyeceğine yetişemeyeceğini
düşünen anne ve babaların içini
rahatlatmak benzer bir şekilde Kinoa
yemediği için de zayıflayamadığını
düşünen insanların yine bu yanlış
bilgisini düzeltmek isterim Her Bir
besinin bir besin değeri var ve hiçbir
besin mucizevi değil mesela bir çocuk
Eğer brokoli yemiyorsa başka sebzeleri
yiyerek de gayet rahat bir şekilde
büyüyebilir ve gelişebilir kinaya
ulaşamıyorsanız ya da Kinoa yemekten
hoşlanmıyorsanız Eğer kendi
topraklarımızı yetişen tahılları yiyerek
de gayet sağlıklı ve tabii ki kalori
açığı Yakalayarak zayıflayabilirsiniz
Ben Mersin'de doğdum büyüdüm ve benim
doğduğum büyüdüğüm topraklarda avokado
bol miktarda bulunuyordu ve ben avokado
yemeği çok severim ama size wakao yemek
zorunda değilsiniz Bunun yerine
zeytinyağı da tüketebilirsiniz
Hatta bunları bu şekilde çeşitlendirmek
sağlığınız için oldukça büyük bir fayda
da sağlayabilir
üçüncü ve son bahsetmek istediğim konu
zayıflamak zorunda değilsiniz daha ince
bacaklar daha ince bir bel tartıda
azalan rakamlar eşittir daha sağlıklı
mutlu huzurlu bir Siz demek değil
sağlığınızla ilgili Eğer ki yönetmeniz
gerekiyorsa da tartıdaki azalan
rakamları değil de bu azalan rakamlara
giden davranışları düzenlemek kalıcı bir
kilo kaybı sizin için sağlayabilir
Nasıl ki o markete gittiğinizde
aklınızda hiç yokken bir an mutlaka
reçeli almam lazım gibi düşünüyorsunuz
ya da zencefil reçelinin mi yoksa ahudu
reçeli mi sizin için daha iyi bir tercih
olduğunu düşünüyorsunuz benzer bir
şekilde çevrenizdeki insanlar sürekli
olarak zayıflamadan bahsediyorsa ya da
zayıflıyorsa siz de zayıflamak zorunda
gibi hissedebilirsiniz
zayıflamak zorundasınız o plates
eğitmenine gitmek zorundasınız o okula
gitmek zorundasınız lazımlar bir sürü
lazım
biz bu bilgilere kendi ihtiyacımızı
anlamaktansa çevremizdekiler nasıl
yapıyor ona bakarak Aslında karar
veriyoruz Üstelik markete sadece tuvalet
kağıdı almaya gitmiş ya
benzer bir şekilde yaptığımız
tercihlerin bizi nasıl bir insan
yaptığını birçok kişisel gelişim
kitabında okumuşsunuzdur diye tahmin
ediyorum
ben bu önermeye birazcık Neden sonuç
ilişkisi içerisinde oturtulmuş ve
bağlamdan yoksun bir önerme olarak
görüyorum
Yetişkin bir insanın günde 35 bine yakın
tercih yaptığını biliyoruz
bu tercihler arasında Tabii ki böyle
zencefil reçeli mi alayım yoksa ahududu
gibi daha gündelik ya da eğer o güne
denk geldiyse diyetisyenlik mi okuyayım
yoksa tiyatro mu gibi daha büyük bir
kararda denk gelmiş olabilir Bir gün
içerisinde 35 bin tercih her bir
tercihinde en az iki tane seçeneğin ne
olduğunu düşünürsek nasıl bir insan
olacağımızı bir formülasyona oturtarak
sağlıklı mutlu huzurlu fit gibi
seçenekler çıkartmak Sizce anlamlı mı
sadece beslenme konusunda ya da bu
bahsettiğim konuda değil birçok
tercihimizi yaparken Aslında bu
tercihlerin bizde yarattığı
sorumluluktan kaçabilmemiz adına neden
sonuç ilişkisine başvuruyoruz ve Aslında
bu durum bizi kendimizden uzaklaştırıyor
benimse hayatında verdiğim en büyük
kararlardan biri meslek tercihimle
alakalıydı
küçüklüğümden beri diyetisyen olmak
istiyordum ve çok severek kazandığım
beslenme bölümünden sonra psikoloji
bölümüyle çifttan dal yapmaya başladım
şu an aldığım kararın üzerinden 11 sene
geçti o zaman da şimdi de aldığım
karardan oldukça memnunum işimi işimi
yapış şekli mi çok çok seviyorum ve çoğu
zaman kendimi oldukça başarılı
hissediyorum
Peki benim bu psikoloji bölümünü tercih
etmem bir de üzerine memnun olmam bir
şans mıydı Loto bana mı vurmuştu benim
bu tercihimin en büyük sebebi meraklı
merak Belki sizin tercihlerinize çok
önemli bir sebep olmayabilir ama
gerçekten dikkate alınması gereken bir
şey olduğunu düşünüyorum mesela sahnede
olmanın nasıl bir şey hissi olduğunu
merak etsen belki tiyatrocu daha olmak
isterdim ya da tiyatro okumak da
isterdim diye Aslında tahmin ediyorum
merakım sadece beslenmenin psikolojiye
Psikolojinin beslenmeye olan ilişkisini
anlamak değildi Emin olun bir dönemde
Yaklaşık 16 tane dersi bunun için almak
istemezsiniz sadece
merakım kendimle ilgiliydi
küçüklüğümden beri kendimi kaygı
seviyesi çok yüksek çok stresli bir de
üzerine duygusal birisi olarak
tanımlardım küçüklüğümden beri basketbol
oynuyordum her maça çıkarken çok stresli
olmama rağmen bundan inanılmaz bir keyif
Has ve aynı zamanda Neşe de duyuyordum
bu kadar stres kaygı ve Neşe nasıl aynı
sayfada olabiliyordu Bu benim için hiç
farklı bir şey değildi ama Toplumsal
olarak bu çok kabul gören bir şey
değildi ve benim kafamı karıştırmaya
başlamıştı olayları anlamlandırabilmek
adına bir Neden sonuç ilişkisi kurdum
Bende devam eden zamanlarda akademik
başaramın da insan ilişkilerinde
arkadaşlık ilişkilerinde iyi olmasını
strese bağlamaya başladım Eğer ki bir
konu hakkında yeterince kaygılanırsam
ancak o zaman hedefime ulaşabilirdim Ama
dediğim gibi bu oldukça tezattı ve
kafamı karıştırıyordu bunu bir tek
yaşayan ben miydim benzer bir şekilde
mesleğimde de böyle bir şey olabilirdi
yani Birisi Herkesin yaptığı şeyi
yapmadan Sağlıklı ve mutlu olduğu için
bu kafa karışıklığını yaşayabilirdi
hem kendi İhtiyaçlarımı karşılandığı
için hem de mesleğime katkı
sağlayabileceği için psikoloji okumaya
karar vermiştim Yani bu bir Tesadüf
değildi
Peki benim yolumu takip edecek olan
herkesin benim gibi memnun olması bir
Garanti mi Bunu maalesef Sizlerde bende
bilemiyoruz İşte bu yüzden nasıl bir
insan oluruzun tam bir formülasyonu yok
insan
bildiğimiz kadarıyla En azından
öleceğini bilen tek canlı ve bununla
birlikte bu yüzden çok büyük bir kaygıyı
beraberinde taşıyor bu kaygıyı
düşünürken Tabii hepimiz birbirimizin
hayatından bilgi ilham Ve çoğu zamanda
güç alıyoruz Ben de okuduğum her şeyden
üçe aldım Öncelikle kaygının ve kaygılı
olmanın insana dair bir şey olduğunu
öğrendim kaygı kötü bir şey değildi
kaygı yaratmakla ilgiliydi yaratmakla ve
hatta yaratıcılıkla ilgili idi ama
yaratıcılık öyle elma gibi ağaçtan
toplanmıyordu bir insanın yaratıcı
olabilmesi için aynı zamanda cesarete
ihtiyacı vardı
cesaretin umutsuzluğa rağmen devam
edebilme gücü olduğunu rollemeyin bir
kitabında okumuştum o kadar
etkilenmiştim ki tıpkı bir dönme gibi
derime kazmak istemiştim
daha sonra devam eden zamanlarda almak
güç almaya aynı şekilde devam ettim
bahsettiğim gibi insan öleceğini bilen
tek canlı ve zaten Sadece bu bilgi bile
kaygılı olması için oldukça yeterli
insan öleceğini bilen tek canlı ve
önündeki Ortalama olarak 70 ile 100
senelik ömründe ömründeki seçeneklerden
Herhangi birini seçtiği takdirde hayat
boyu bu seçeneğin şimdiki ve bundan
sonraki bütün sonuçlarıyla tek başına
yalnız başına yaşamak zorunda dilimize
pelesenk olan varoluşsal kaygı tam
olarak bu demek hepimizin ortak olarak
farklı şekillerde deneyimlediği ve
dediğim gibi seçimlerimizde yalnız
olduğumuzun gerçeği
sadece bu değil aynı zamanda özgürlük de
kaygı yaratıyor yani seçme özgürlüğümüz
Çünkü aslında hepimiz biliyoruz ki küçük
ya da büyük potansiyel olarak
yapabileceğimiz her şeyin Ama her şeyin
bu dünyada bir etkisi var
günümüzde herkes herkesin ne isterse
olabileceğinden bahsediyor işinizi
sevmiyorsanız değiştirin yeniden
başlamak için hiçbir zaman geç değil bir
bilet alın ve gidin buralardan Oh ne
kadar güzel yanlış anlaşılmasın Bunların
hepsine ben de katılıyorum ancak nereye
giderseniz gidin kendinize yanınızda
götürüyorsunuz nereye giderseniz gidin
kim ne olursanız olun ne olursanız olun
seçimlerin getirdiği kaygıda her zaman
sizinle beraber olacak o yüzden daha çok
para kazanarak o olarak bu olarak değil
yani daha kaygısız bir hayat için değil
kendi özünüzü keşfetmek için bu
dünyadaki kıymetli zamanınızı
geçirmenizi öneririm
bir işin en iyisi olmak için değil ne
olmak istiyorsanız ne hissetmek
istiyorsanız bunun için çalışmanızı
zamanınızı ve emeğinizi harcamanızı
öneririm
Belki bugün Sizler de ben de burada
olmayı tercih ettik belki paralel bir
evrende sizin bozuk paranız Döne dolaşıp
bir başkasının cebine girebilirdi bugün
buraya gelmektense bu saatte metroda
olmayı Tercih edebilirsiniz metroda
hayatınızın aşkıyla karşılaşıp
çarpıştığınızda Kitaplarınızı Yere
düşerken Aşık olabilirdiniz ya da bu
güzel cumartesi'yi En sevdiğiniz
kahvecide geçirmek üzere yola çıkmışken
trafik kazası yapıp şu anda trafik
tutanağı da tutuyor olabilirdiniz Ama
siz de ben de bugün burada olmanın
şimdiki bundan sonraki bütün sonuçları
ile tek başımıza hayat boyu birlikte
sözlerimi son zamanlarda internette
gördüğüm en iyi şeyi paylaşarak Aslında
bitirmek istiyorum
bu şiiri 7 yaşında İsmail isimli küçük
bir çocuk yazmış ben bu şeyi de okuduğum
zaman içimde anlaşıldığıma dair
inanılmaz güzel bir his oluştu belki
İsmail de siz de ben de bu dünyadaki
bütün tercihlerimizde tek başımızayız
belki annemiz babamız sevdiklerimiz
yanımızda Ama dediğim gibi bu
tercihlerin sonuçlarını hep beraber ama
yalnız başımıza yaşıyoruz
Ben neyim Ben bir kara delik miyim ben
bir Kek miyim ben bir iki miyim ben bir
İsmail miyim ben bir hiç miyim ben bir
hiçliğin ortasında yüzen bir adam mıyım
ben hiçbir şey miyim Yoksa bunlar bir
yalan mı Belki bir şey olabilirim
Çünkü gerçekten önünüzde yapacağınız
bazı tercihler berbat sonuçlanacak
bazılarından da inanılmaz memnun
kalacaksınız ve bunların hiçbirini
denemeden bilemeyeceksiniz ama belki bir
gün
rastgele tuvalet kağıdı almak için
gittiğiniz Bir markette hayatınızın
reçelini bulduğunuzda şaşıracaksınız
teşekkür ederim
[Alkış]